allons cuisiner ce que les shérifs sont
ici pourquoi sont-ils ici mon nom est Rick
Carver Je suis un courtier immobilier agréé
cette maison a été saisie non je n'ai
pas l'air content et toi ta mère et ton
fils quittent la propriété ce n'est pas
votre  propre M. Carr travaillant s'il vous plaît ne savez pas
si vous avez deux minutes en arrière
tout ce dont vous avez besoin oh mon dieu doit-
il rester là pendant qu'elle fait
ses bagages est-ce vrai oh mon dieu oh mon dieu
ils prévoient de rester un moment juste
couple  nuits comprendre je n'ai pas le
choix tu me vires hier je ne t'ai pas
viré de la banque as-tu fait de la
construction je paierai cinquante dollars en liquide
est-ce que tu te moques de moi cinquante dollars
ne devrait pas être une blague pour toi fils
toi '  je fais avec lui tu dois travailler tu
sais donc ce que ma maison en arrière ne devient pas
émotif à propos de l'immobilier c'est ma
maison familiale si tu veux j'ai besoin de savoir
que j'ai quelqu'un qui peut gérer n'importe quelle
situation 24 heures sur 24, 7 jours sur 7, il a mis des avis sur ma
fenêtre  quand tu travailles pour moi ton esprit
veux-tu doubler ce que tu fais  de nous
voler est ce vol
ressemble un peu à des ennuis que
pensez-vous que cela signifierait travailler pour moi
mr.  Tanner déteste dire que votre expulsion est
prévue pour la journée afin que je puisse mettre un
toit sur votre tête comme un prudent n'est-
ce pas tout cela vaut ne soyez pas doux vous
pensez que l'Amérique donne le cul d'un rat volant
à votre sujet pour moi nous pouvons l'Amérique ne  ne
renfloue pas les perdants tu m'as expulsé moi et ma
famille de notre oh je ne te connais pas je
sais que l'
Amérique a été construite en renflouant les gagnants
une nation de vos gagnants au
revoir
un seul sur des centaines va monter sur
cette arche Soleil chaque  autre pauvre âme
va te noyer
toi